yeah hip-hop lifts San Francisco
California in urban centers across the
globe there's a new ride in town ly F -
fist bump if you wanna ride with me
swipe I bet you wanna ride with me now
why I bet you wanna ride with me now oh
yeah
decoe aka hip hop lift isn't your
average cabbie he's one of a growing
number of car owners turning their set
of wheels into a money spinner the
essential tool is a smartphone app so
efficient you know my friend customers
can summon a car in seconds
the meteoric rise of ride-hailing apps
around the world is one part of a global
transport revolution if you go into any
major metropolitan area car ownership is
is down pretty substantially and we talk
a lot about how riding is the new
driving our changing attitudes towards
driving a pressing car makers to embrace
a future that's less about horsepower
and more about processing power you just
have that perfect storm of all these
different technologies coming together
in one place across the world old
industries are facing disruption on an
unprecedented scale people are not
taking over Texas confronted by
ever-changing technology the pressure to
adapt has never been greater it is
always survival of the fittest that's
capitalism because where there's threat
there's also opportunity
Bangalore India one of the
fastest-growing ride-hailing markets in
the world settings shanton joined Ola
cabs three years ago to become one of
Bangalore's first female auto rickshaw
drivers with her job she's challenging
attitudes in this traditional city a
millionaire lubricant red brick peroneal
terrain and and Videla voila
van Bommel a Burakumin chair Yago the
model yi Samba customer pick I thought
modernity and sexy our studio us today
in on a wall on Le what's the name our
tone train Martin who's she
you have a loop on the post polymer on
even lady suit to move upon shaggy day
engineer yesterday I provide Petrova
Mota one or whenever correct very like
Ola is India's most popular on demand
right service with 1 million booking
requests every day for 350,000 vehicles
including rickshaws
founded just five years ago the company
is now valued at five billion dollars
although it's not just a cab company our
mission and our vision and the
opportunity for us is to build mobility
for a billion Indians in on for the
future we are a technology company we
don't own a single cab we operate a
marketplace where we aggregate the
supply we are get the demand and we
connect them in the most efficient way
possible owners app connects drivers in
their vehicles with customers needing a
ride just two percent of Indians owned
their own vehicle but by 2017 20 percent
of the countries one and a quarter
billion population will own a smartphone
the market potential is huge there are
around 200 million more Trice trips a
day in open India there's a long way to
go for us our mission is to add value in
each of those trips but one group isn't
along for the ride local cabbies
I'm irrelevant got a will over say roll
over Johnny chai yet I'm under a
kilometer so larvik elevator lathe am i
over medic are you ready but we have our
Acharya Boris house in other countries
the licensed taxi drivers are unhappy
the ride hailing apps are undercutting
their fares
we are totally angry with this company
or year up nature of circuit parameter
of seed array or market marriage Joep
Whatcom rate with a race one sonora
bachata a marriage gari a canoe year
driver shortage anyway Christina de re
to'em logo GoBot Rosa do Callaghan Jaya
Carlo
now the struggling taxi drivers
themselves are being courted by Ola they
feel that they're losing business the
great thing is that they can also come
onto our platform it's not as if we are
leaving them out we are saying we'll
work with everybody oh let's drive to
expand is partly to keep up with a
meteoric rise of international
competitors like uber owners formed a
global partnership with Asia's biggest
ride-hailing services and rising
American star lifts a company that
distinguishes itself by its trademark
pink mustache the deal will enable these
companies riders to seamlessly use each
other's apps when abroad david rust is
lifts head of strategic operations
that's all happened going from San
Francisco to covering half the world's
population in just about four years
we have over 700 people working here we
have other offices in Nashville and
Seattle as well
big part of our brand is how to have fun
while getting from point A to point B
and we wanted that to greet you right
when you come in the office
Ubah may be better known but lift claims
to be the fastest-growing ride-hailing
app in the u.s. last year alone its
number of rides and revenue increased
fivefold for david rust this uptake is
impacting what was once viewed a
fundamental right of passage buying your
first car for the younger generation
it's a whole different ball game because
envision that you grow up owning a
smartphone from a very young age and you
grow up being able to request a ride
from a young age so now when you hit you
know age 16 age 18 when you know
individuals here in the United States
you know normally would get a car and
that's the sign of freedom then you
drive to high school and it's and it's a
big event now you can just request a
lift and that's how many kids are
growing up this day and age and it
totally changes that paradigm of freedom
being driving to freedom being riding a
University of Michigan study has
revealed a marked decline in the number
of new drivers in America over the past
three decades it found the percentage of
20 to 24 year olds with driving licenses
fell from 92 percent to 77 percent among
18 euros there was an even bigger drop
of 20 percent
they don't want the hassle of owning a
car maintaining a car buying insurance
for the car parking the car for it to
sit idle 96% of the time what a what a
passenger wants is to get from point A
to point B at an affordable rate in an
enjoyable way and when you build that
experience it is going to disrupt the
industry because that means you're not
owning a car
it's a vision that should strike fear
into the heart of the auto industry Ford
is the second largest car manufacturer
in the US and has relied on selling
vehicles for well over a century
although Ford's boss grew up in this era
of unquestioned car ownership he's aware
it might not continue forever the first
day I was able to go down to the
Department of Motor Vehicles to get my
license I did because at the time having
a vehicle meant freedom and for me to
connect with my friends fast forward to
today you have young people that have
all these enabling technologies whether
it's their smartphones and their their
their iChatting or they're playing
online their video games or their
texting or whatever you know that
particular need of a vehicle has
somewhat diminished Ford has just
reported its best annual sales
performance in a decade while it seems
unlikely the company would turn its back
on a winning formula Ford in sisters
preparing for a future where sales are
no longer driven by the latest model we
are fundamentally rethinking our whole
product development traditionally in our
industry it's been about producing the
product that thing now we are very much
thinking what experience do we want to
provide the customer
it's pushing the company into unexpected
areas
Ford's go drive hire service is one
pilot scheme encouraging people to share
its vehicles while Ford shuttle buses
are trialing rides on demand the
companies even experimenting with
electric bikes all it claims in an
effort to become less reliant on the
traditional business model of a big
one-off purchase we're looking at some
of these new enabling technologies as a
huge opportunity so things that we're
seeing around mobility around
connectivity or vehicles as they become
part of the Internet of Things it's
really important for us to look at
societal trends because it's about
having one foot in today but also one
foot in tomorrow and understanding what
does that world going to look like 5 10
and 15 years from now since the 1950s
Ford and its competitors have tried to
anticipate what will appeal to the car
users of tomorrow or ro control um the
idea that cars can be about the joy of
the ride is nothing new safe comfortable
mind if I smoke cigar all that with this
wonderful air conditioning but the auto
manufacturers aren't the only ones vying
for the passengers of the future Silicon
Valley the global hub of technology it
may be two and a half thousand miles
from Detroit but it's here where a
modern-day fight for the soul of the
motorcar is playing out
the latest threat to the car industry
comes from tech giants like Google who
believe they have the expertise to
deliver the driverless car Forge
response to pitch up on their doorstep
we want to participate in that community
we want to collaborate with that
community but importantly we want to be
viewed as part of the community and not
just some transactional partner that
flies in and you know buys a technology
or something like that Ford's new
Research Center is the company's latest
attempt to protect its legacy here
they're determined to avoid a future
where Ford cars are just the shell for
another company's technology it's
training the network is evaluating how
well the networking works so they're
building the tech themselves determine
that car makers will be the ones to
bring the driverless car to market each
of these have 32 laser beams own and
every single one of those is collecting
information based on the path of flight
between the laser fires out when it
comes back we have two antennae here
one in the front and one in the rear and
because we know the distance between
them we can actually figure out both
very with high level precision where the
vehicle is as well as the direction the
vehicles pointed there are no blind
spots with the way these sensors are set
up so that allows us to see the entire
environment at all times and three
dimensions enabling a car to see its
surroundings is one challenge
identifying humans over inanimate
objects is another perfecting this
software is one of the hardest tasks
facing any company trying to create a
safe driverless car let alone a car
company playing catch-up you can see all
of the blue boxes that are showing up
around the people so you see it's only
grabbing people in this frame it's not
grabbing the furniture in the room so
basically the way this machine learning
algorithm works is it it sort of teaches
itself much away human learners to
detect different objects and starts to
recognize patterns so if you put this
onto a car when you're driving down the
road your vehicle can tell the
difference between like a fire hydrant
or a trash can and a human that might be
running
to the road until very recently this was
impossible to run in real time as you
can see if I step out of the frame the
the moment I step into it I'm boxed in
less than a second so that kind of quick
response time to where the system can
immediately detect that this is a human
and I need to avoid this at all costs
that information is really important for
driving in the city Ford isn't the only
car maker taking on the software giants
Mercedes Nissan and others are all
developing their own driverless cars but
they'll still have to face the
possibility that the general public
might not want to own them preferring
the flexibility of ride-hailing someone
else's vehicle how you doing my friend
all right all right all right
I created a hip-hop trivia game that I
actually play with my passengers I'll
give it my best shot
okay well my question for you is this
how much money in debt it's Kanye West
supposedly in right now I'm gonna give
it to you anyway because you're close
you're definitely up there and it's
actually 53 million car makers are
trying to answer another question how to
find customers and generate revenue in
the long term and car hailing app lyft
could provide one of the answers in 2016
US giant General Motors invested half a
billion dollars in this four year old
startup it's a groundbreaking deal to
combine forces and develop a fleet of
shared driverless cars
you take the hardware and manufacturing
operations of General Motors and you
pair that with the the you know network
and and system and all most operating
system capabilities of lyft and it's
really a step towards what the future
looks like
a software becomes an ever more
important factor in how we get around
and the commercial benefits of getting a
share of the ride become more apparent
it's clear today's car makers will do
whatever it takes to stay in the driving
seat when you look at the revenue that
people are spending on moving around
whether it's mass transit or uber or
motorcycles or whatever put aside planes
that revenue that's about five and a
half to six trillion dollars we get zero
percent of that we're looking at that is
a huge opportunity
Oh